j'accueille reno et mélanie de temps
court
bonsoir mais l'ennemi la dernière fois
que vous êtes venu j'espérais que ce fut
la dernière il n'en est rien votre mère
ingrid betancourt 42 ans ex candidate
des verts à la présidentielle en
colombie est toujours détenu depuis le
23 février 2002 par la guérilla marxiste
des farc les forces armées
révolutionnaires de colombie
en fait la branche armée du parti
communiste colombien voilà alors
jusqu'au 23 février 2002 votre maman il
est des encours avait mené contre la
pauvreté la corruption et le trafic de
drogue une lutte exemplaire qui ne peut
que susciter notre respect
alors mme evans y avait donc trois ans
et demi civile bettencourt est otage des
farc
quand avez vous eu des nouvelles pour la
dernière fois les dernières nouvelles
que nous avons eues d'elle date ma
demande il ya plus de besoins voit une
preuve de vie une cassette vidéo où elle
était forte
tellement forte mais adoption de rien on
n'a pas de preuves de vie on sait
qu'elle est en vie quand on interview
raul reyes qui est le numéro deux des
farc qui dit toujours que qu'elle est en
bonne santé comme les autres otages mais
ce n'est pas une preuve de vie mais oui
nature en la force du vent alors renault
c'est au troisième anniversaire de sa
détention que vous avez pris contact
avec le comité de soutien à ingrid
betancourt vous regrettiez plus tôt je
regrette ce qui pénalise un peu mais bon
le maul jour où je les fais il se trouve
que dans le comité met en cours un faux
et dans les comités de soutien j'ai
était non seulement le seul chanteur à
être présent à manifester ma solidarité
et j'étais aussi la seule personnalité
personnes là par marek halter qui a
participé quelques actions dans les rues
et dans l'est sur la parvis des droits
de l'homme avec les amis les membres
anonymes des comités de soutien et la
famille bettencourt
donc il n'est jamais trop tard et
aujourd'hui il ya deux artistes qui ont
rejoint ce combat et de mananara
d'autres encore et j'essaye mes petits
moyens de motiver les artistes
internationaux qui ont participé à
travers une chanson à sensibiliser les
populations en france et partout dans le
monde pour alors aujourd'hui voudriez
que la mobilisation pour une ride
bettencourt soit comparable à celle qui
a eu pour florence aubenas par exemple
c'est à dire une mobilisation générale
de ces aimants lutz était formidable
c'est eu lieu pour les otages français
en irak
je regrette que ce soit pas le cas pour
les bettencourt par la prochaine
manifestation pour une grille
bettencourt c'est lundi le 24 octobre à
19h au théâtre du rond-point s'est situé
au rond point des champs elysées et vous
allez chanter la chanson que avec bucolo
vous avez écrite pour elle vu coiffer
musique c'est absolument magnifique
très
spedding faisons un peu pensé
musicalement à ce qu'a été sa cohérente
et il ya une vingtaine d'années une
chanson très mélodies très porteuse qui
met mes mots mais peut tenir mes petits
mots en valeur chanson était temps fort
est adapté par johnny clegg pour
l'europe et l'afrique
mais la version espagnole par un artiste
argentan et le mailing ok formidable et
aussitôt on va en faire fabriquer une
centaine d'exemplaires pour l'envoyer
très vite en colombie où des radios
libres
la diffusion en espérant que les otages
entendront ce message de solidarité de
façade des artistes et des citoyens
européens
ce sera transférée dans la jungle
avec ses portes fin de
les geôliers
ceux-ci de staline ou de lise mao à toi
qui
j'imagine préférerai
peut-être
moi j'ai dû la guerre fils de cheikh
ibra
de lumière
social
du grand soir cela m
et le mal et surtout les dollars